and today's starting pitcher for game
two
here at comerica is tarik school derrick
making his third start and he got to sit
there and watch matthew boyd kind of
execute
he's going to try to get his change up
down in the zone a little bit better
today he had a better start his second
timeout
the 6-2-2 on the way ground ball line
drive right to
well came to lario at first thought it
was a one-hopper but he caught it cruz
what a battle matt whistler making his
third opening as an opener making his
ninth appearance overall 14 innings only
seven hits allowed third appearance in a
row where he's been the opener
and candelario drops it in for a single
to put runners at the corners for niko
good run he got him strike three in the
dirt picked up by jeffers off the first
base line throws him out and that's the
inning the twins have runners at the
corners with nobody out threatening here
for marvin gonzalez there's a drive to
left field
and there to make the catch
is stewart trotting home as rosario and
it's one nothing twins probably
rosario's hustle right there gets
gonzales and a run batted in trevor may
trying to get the final out here in the
second two on two out twins lead one
nothing he got him strike three on a
high fast ball at 98. one out run around
and here's candelario fly ball right
field hit it way back in right and go on
a home run
jamer candelario put a charge into a
fastball a two-run shot number three and
the tigers take a 2-1 lead here in the
third well you're the holy mackerel
mabel you talk about a
double buggy whip right there that ball
was a line shot 20 rows up the right
center field gap right here at this
ballpark that ball went out in a hurry
you could tell by the track at the back
cruise homered in his last at bat of
game one get his count right here that
ball is crushed into left field
stewart's just going to turn around and
this game's tied up a
shot for nelson cruz on a changeup 13th
homer this season tied up 2-2 takes over
the league lead in home runs
back and show off that power
chanel can get in that home run trot too
to center field
victor reyes
and did he make this yes he did
victor reyes stole a home run away from
miguel
perfect timing
and reyes keeps it tied at two
cameron maven at the plate and the pitch
that one's hit into center field look
out might have a chance get up in that
jet stream cave back jumps up
and cave makes the catch the center
fielders taking center stage okay says
to reyes take that
second walk of the ball game and that'll
bring up cabrera fly ball right field
off the bat at cabrera this one's deep
and way back and gone a home run
miguel cabrera two run double in the
first game two run home run here in the
fifth in game two
number five
and the tigers take a 4-2 lead here in
the fifth my goodness
making his 17th appearance he's worked
16 and two thirds innings allowed only
10 hits
five walks 18 strikeouts
next kepler is over five in the two
games with three strikeouts fly ball
center field softly hit reyes charging
in dives and he made the catch
victor reyes has gone back to take a
home run away from ceno and he just came
in to take a bloop hit away from kepler
a dive at the last big smile on his face
that's out number three in the top of
the sixth inning the art of playing the
outfield there it was soto is a
hard-throwing left-hander but the twins
have a right-hand cruise a lefty and
rosario a righty and snow and then
hopefully a switcher in gonzalez the
line drive into right center field
that's the base hit good start crew
singles the opposite way mishandled
briefly by mabin but nelson hangs on
near first the lead-off man is on nobody
out and now the batter is eddie rosario
is low ball four
so here we go two on nobody out
the time run is on the go ahead run is
now coming up and miguel is to know
on the ground to third paradis
to second scope relay in time
a huge double play for the tigers here
in the seventh
that's just what he wanted
and he gets the result he wants
good job by parade he's getting rid of
that ball quickly to scope here's the
3-2
got him looking
the tigers sweep the twin bill
from minnesota gregory soto converts his
first career save giving tarik skubal
his first career win
outstanding defense from victor reyes a
couple of two-run homers one from miguel
cabrera the other from jamer candelario
and it's a happy saturday in detroit